Francia se prepara para afrontar su
novena oleada de Kobe 19 y para los
ciudadanos podría ser el momento de
regresar a los viejos hábitos ya que
muchos en el país están pidiendo que
vuelva a ser obligatorio el uso de las
mascarillas en el transporte público
[Música]
creo que es esencial que vuelva la
mascarilla mucha gente tose y nadie sabe
respetar las normas de distanciamiento
social yo tengo mi mascarilla pero
mientras no sea obligatoria no me la
pondré porque me molesta el gobierno
francés dice estar listo para tomar
medidas si la novena ola se sale de
control antes de las vacaciones
sí un cochinillo monté si las
infecciones siguen aumentando no dudaré
en hacer obligatorio las mascarillas
desde hace un mes los casos de Kobe 19
han vuelto a aumentar en Francia la
semana pasada hubo una media de
50,604 casos diarios es decir el doble
de infecciones que a principios de
noviembre y el tema de las vacunas
vuelve a estar en el centro del debate
no estoy vacunado no me he puesto la
primera ni la segunda dosis nos fuimos
de vacaciones Así que tuvimos que
asegurarnos de tener todas nuestras
dosis las autoridades siguen haciendo
campaña para que todos se vacunen ya que
solo el 21% de los mayores de 80 años y
más ha recibido todas las